bonsoir alexis poulain couvre feu donc à
18h partout en france ou bien confirmant
les week-ends ou encore confinement tout
court votre pronostic pour demain soir
je ne sais pas de toute façon ces
mesures liberticides ces mesures
coercitives ces mesures autoritaires
n'ont rien à voir avec la gestion
sanitaire de la crise si on voulait
gérer la crise eh bien on utiliserait
les médicaments qu'on à disposition pour
soigne en amour avec le peu d'effet
qu'ils ont mais au moins essayer
quelques quelques protocoles qui ont
fait leurs preuves
certains pays sont revenus sur ce qu'ils
avaient dit sur l'ivermectine la cure
aux kids ou d'autres donc on pourrait
déjà essayé ça le vaccin bien sûr
vacciner davantage aujourd'hui on voit
bien que le problème c'est le goulot
d'étranglement au niveau de la
production files heures modern as c'est
que deux candidats vaccins en plus avec
cette technologie de la rn messager et
il n'en produisent pas assez pour tout
le monde et donc on se retrouve à gérer
encore une pénurie comme c'était le cas
de la pénurie des masses la pénurie des
tec ou des têtes des tests enfin c'est
toujours à peu près la même histoire je
le disais hier d'ailleurs on est dans ce
jour sans fin qui n'en finit pas avec
conseil de défense allocution jean
castex d'olivier ferrand pour nous
expliquer que ça va mal que c'est
toujours un peu notre faute mais que ça
va aller mieux après le printemps après
l'été c'est à peu près toujours les
mêmes dates c'est à dire qu'une fois que
la deuxième vague sera passé comme dans
tous ces virus qu'on a eues il va
disparaître comme il est apparu
et puis on dira merci super c'était
grâce au vaccin tout ça mais confiné
encore une fois soit on le fait
sérieusement et à ce moment là tous les
pays européens confine au même moment en
fermant totalement leurs frontières sauf
pour des cas d'urgence bien entendu avec
une campagne de vaccination avec tous
les candidats vaccins et j'apprends que
l'union européenne a commencé des
pourparlers pour avoir également le
vaccin spoutnik v qui pourrait arriver
en europe également
ou bien on continue de faire n'importe
quoi mais à ce moment là on dont la
liberté à tout le monde parce que ça ne
sert à rien de saboter le monde de la
culture le monde de la restauration le
monde du tourisme tout le monde de la
nuit qui n'a pas rouvert depuis le mois
de mars
si finalement les forts ne sert à rien
et qu'est ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui
c'est que tous ces efforts ont servi
certes mais à la marge vous avez autant
d'études sur le marché que de façon
d'envisager les confinements qui disent
que finalement ces mesures elles peuvent
marcher mais très peu en comparaison de
l'effort qu'on demande aux uns et aux
autres
et là il a le problème qu'on va avoir
après cette crise sanitaire très mal
géré c'est l'ampleur de la crise
économique et je crois que là les
économies européennes et l'économie
française n'est pas prête
et ce n'est pas bruno le maire avec des
projections à 6% qui va changer quoi que
ce soit ça c'est de l'incantation ce
n'est pas du réel on est en train de
préparer des faillites des dettes qui ne
seront pas rembourser des emprunts qui
ne sont pas remboursés et donc une
faillite systémique de tout un système
avec bien sûr un taux de chômage qui va
qui va exploser et la précarité des plus
jeunes étudiants on a vu un ces derniers
jours les suicides et tentatives de
suicide
la précarité dans laquelle se retrouvent
les plus jeunes aujourd'hui à cause de
ces mesures coercitives autoritaire qui
ne sont pas des mesures sanitaires
rappelons le alexis poulain vous avez
évoqué les conseils de défense qui se
succèdent les mesures de restriction
également qui dit et conseil de défense
dit évidemment prise de parole du porte
parole du gouvernement gabriel attal
on écoute il ya aujourd'hui dans notre
pays à la fois des mesures de portée
nationale et des mesures de portée
locale
il ya des mesures de portée nationale je
pense au couvre-feu à 20 heures je pense
au télétravail très fortement
recommandée obligatoire lorsque il est
possible dans nos entreprises
et puis il ya des applications locales
des mesures locales je pense évidemment
départements qui sont passés à 18h en
cours au feu et c'est tout à fait une
logique qui peut
se poursuivre je ne parle pas des
mesures en tant que tel je parle du fait
d'avoir à la fois un socle de mesures
nationales et des renforcements au
niveau local si c'est nécessaire
voilà alexis poulain on vient d'écouter
le porte parole du gouvernement qui
parle de mesures locales qui parle
également de ce couvre-feu peut être
étendue à 18 heures comment prendre en
considération cette nouvelle donne du
variant anglais sans pénaliser à la fois
l'économie ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure sans pénaliser également de
moral des français
le verrions anglais il fallait le traité
à la source c'est-à-dire qu'à partir du
moment où on a appris à la la la la
virulence de cette nouvelle souche il
fallait couper les arrivées massives de
retard à la gare du nord ça a pété fait
donc on a eu on a accueilli à nouveau le
virus sans affiche cette fois ci on l'a
juste fait comme si c'était normal comme
si tout allait bien et puis on verra
plus tard
donc on a toujours à peu près à mois de
retard sur ce virus
et pourtant c'était très facile à un
moment de dire bon bah écoutez si vous
voulez trois mois difficiles à tenir
selon les propos de jean françois
delfraissy
ce matin il propose de ne pas fermer les
écoles maintenant alors que nos voisins
européens eux le fait par exemple ce que
je vous disais on se coordonner pour que
vraiment le virus cessent de circuler et
donc on ferme les écoles ont fait un
véritable confinement mais avec tous les
voisins européens et sa plus courte
du coup ça pourrait être quinze jours
trois semaines j'imagine avec la
campagne de vaccination qui suit en
parallèle soir on continue chacun à son
rythme de faire n'importe quoi et on
aura le virus encore en 2022 si tout va
bien donc il ya eu je rebondis sur ce
que vous dites vous parlez 2022
évidemment il y aura l'élection
présidentielle aujourd'hui en plus sein
de ce conseil de défense y avait un
séminaire 42 mais l'hist retour du
président
pour préparer peut-être la sortie de
crise l'atmosphère dans laquelle elle se
fera l'économie du pays etc
c'est ça qui était qui et vous qui a été
discuté tout à l'heure au tour d'
emmanuel macron wee cc
alors ça c'est typiquement la start up
nation à faire des séminaires
d'entreprises dont qui sont des
séminaires du gouvernement
pourquoi pour simplement essayer de
préparer ce qui va être la compagne des
nouvelles macro pour la réduction en
2022 en disant qu elle pille on va te
présenter si la campagne de vaccination
acteurs mon chèque comme la gestion
sanitaire était un échec
alors là il ya une chance pour 2022 en
revanche s'il arrive à avoir un prénom à
peu près présentable il y aura la crise
économique est là ils auront des aides
qu'ils vont prolonger jusqu'en 2022 on
va trafic est un peu les chiffres du
chômage on va continuer avec ces
entreprises zombies pour dire que tout
va très bien madame la marquise avant
d'avoir la véritable crise qui va
arriver au deuxième semestre 2022 si on
continue toutes ces aides qui vont
coûter un premier de dengue là pour ce
qui est du cas mais bien sûr qu'il faut
sauver l'emploi mais pour ça soyons
malin en position les entreprises de
débaucher d'affaires des plans sociaux
et dont les entreprises mais pour
qu'elle garde l'emploi faisant des
nouvelles taxes aussi il va falloir
trouver de l'argent parce que toute
cette dette qu'on accumule il faudra
trouver un moyen de faire rentrer de
l'argent des caisses de l'état avec une
économie qui elle ne sera pas en forte
croissance donc peut-être qu'ils ont
parlé de ça dans ce séminaire mais j'ai
l'impression que c'est plus un séminaire
politique où on voit jean castex qui cet
après midi à l'assemblée était fier de
la stratégie vaccinale ne voulait pas
d'auto flagellation
donc on a l'impression que c'était pour
remobiliser tout le monde de dire tout
va très bien et le parti en marche et de
vue celui d'une course en avant une
course folle il faut donner l'illusion
du mouvement du progrès du fait que les
réformes avancent alors qu'elles sont
toutes à l'arrêt et que finalement ces
dernières années doit être une année
utile c'est ce que disait emmanuel
macron donc faire croire que beaucoup de
réformes ou encore passé et pourquoi pas
y compris la réforme des retraites même
si tous les partenaires sociaux étaient
vent debout avant cette crise du coup de
rappelez vous il ya rarement
merci alexis poulain d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
éditorialistes